one of mankind's greatest longings is
complete freedom
one of mankind's greatest limitations is
the inability
to ever truly be free we want the
frictionless state of our origins
we want the autonomy of a god we want
the sea of reality to part at the whim
of our fluctuating individual will
we want like is so often the case what
we cannot have
of course there are many different types
of freedom and there are many layers and
nuances within each type
but arguably absolute freedom the
existential sword
and which one is able to do feel and
choose what one wants
how and when they see fit without any
kind of coercion
restraint or imposition this is the
ideal of freedom that drives the
passionate pursuit
of all other forms and perhaps at least
to some large extent
all human activity in general however in
the final analysis
this ultimate end game of freedom
appears to be an incoherent
impossibility at the top of the pyramid
of freedom
even an individual who is lucky enough
to have unfastened all material and
societal shackles
remains unfree restricted and told what
to do
when to do it and why to do it this
individual of course possessing one of
the most basic freedoms
physical freedom can move their body
around the world as they please
but in just this first layer of analysis
obvious restrictions are found
of course they can only move according
to how their body does
and can and can only move through and
with the body
we generally do not see the body as a
ball and chain because we associate part
of who we are with it
and only know of existence through it
but it takes no more than a sick stomach
or migraine headache to realize just how
heavy this coporal weight is
how stricken to and limited by it we are
we are stuck inside
captives to it subject to its faulty and
fragile mechanisms that do
and will break keeping us bound in space
according to its condition
until it finally turns itself off and us
with it
unpreventably and more yet our body
controls much of what we choose to do
with it
how we move it where we move it and why
being told when to eat when to go to the
bathroom when to sleep
when to wake up that is the daily
routine of a prisoner
not a free man
[Music]
of course one can decide to temporarily
resist their bodily
urges and not eat or sleep and so forth
momentarily experiencing a fleeting
distinction between mind and body
but it takes very little time for the
conspiracy between the mind and body to
reveal itself
the mental sensations corollary to the
body state soon compelling the
individual to behave accordingly
and get in line this of course is just
physical issues though
psychologically abstractly the
individual is also able to think and
consider everything
beyond the mere urges and physical
conditions of their body
and environment this much is true but is
not our relationship with the mind in
the realm of thought
ultimately the same as our physical
relationship with the body
we can only think through our mind and
we can only think in the way our mind
thinks
we are given one lens of the world with
one type of software
running on one type of hardware to
process all that we intake and
experience
if an artist was commissioned for a job
and told that they were free to make
anything they wanted
but were then told it must be on an
etch-a-sketch would they really be free
to make anything they wanted only in
some sense
in truth the freest of persons are free
to think and see things how they choose
but only so long as it is with words
that exist through concepts that have
been construed
in a brain that has been built with
respect to an environment that has been
experienced
all moved by the laws of the natural
world
our minds abilities are its constraints
and its constraints inform us what to
think
and see each condition of the brain
working in relation to the world like
levees and dams controlling the flow of
thought each thought
emerging out of the cause and effect
ripples on the surface of its unending
self-orchestrated flow
we are caught in this movement swept
away uncontrollably
without ever choosing where we started
from and where we go
being compelled what to think and how to
see is the report of an indoctrination
not a free man it is a demonstration of
humanity's overzealous ego
and anthropocentrism to think that so
long as no other humans tell them what
to do
they are free man should undoubtedly
strive
fight for and protect all their earthly
freedoms within the physical
social economic and political domains of
the world
but if and once he has the remaining
unsatisfied
existential freedom of which he will
continue to drink and run in lust and
love to try to attain
perhaps requires a different kind of
consideration
freedom can be manifested only in the
void of beliefs
in the absence of axioms and only where
the laws have no more authority than a
hypothesis
wrote emil charon the closest thing to
absolute existential freedom
it seems is freedom from freedom itself
freedom from the constraints that the
concept of freedom imposes
being totally existentially free or
unfree implies being a defined
separate thing that can be contained or
inhabited
by some other thing a human being is a
part of the whole
called by us universe a part limited in
time and space he experiences himself
his thoughts and feelings
as something separate from the rest a
kind of optical delusion of his
consciousness
the striving to free oneself from this
delusion is the one issue of true
religiosity
not to nourish it but to try to overcome
it is the way to reach the attainable
measure of peace of mind
wrote albert einstein in a letter of
condolence to a grieving father
most would likely agree with the premise
that the individual is essentially
associated with their brain
but if so which part of the brain which
area
which spot can you find it can you feel
it
can you locate it when you close your
eyes or point to it
if you took a brain scan no
consciousness is who we are
how we identify ourselves through
experience but consciousness is
when distilled down empirically a
strange empty awareness
malleably undefined and inexorably
connected with everything that makes and
interacts with it
and doesn't you are not the master of
your mind
you are not the servant you are both and
neither
you are your thoughts and the lineage of
every bit of history that they touch to
get to you
you are the words you are hearing and
the mind that is automatically
processing them
you are the mind that will forget them
in some amount of time you are
everything you've ever heard and
perceived
you are everything you've never heard or
perceived you are everything you've ever
hated
you are everything you've ever loved you
are what's inside and what's outside
your mind
your body and your none of the above
if you exist you cannot be free if there
is no you
you cannot be contained by anything
like the desire for perfect unending
happiness the desire for complete and
absolute freedom
is likely impossible but like happiness
it is
in its true ultimate form a state that
comes and goes unattainable in the ideal
but attainable in the moment in the
moments in which we surrender to the
complete unified image of being
unpluralized in all its comforts and
discomforts
when we cease trying to square circles
implicate everything that contests with
us
when we stop trying to escape what
cannot be escaped it is the classic
lesson
the chinese finger trap the tao and
taoism nirvana in buddhism
the silence of wittenstein the harder
one tries
the harder one flails the more
entrenched one becomes
in his poem on freedom khalil gibran
wrote
at the city gate and by your fireside i
have seen you prostrate yourself
and worship your own freedom even as
slaves humble themselves
before a tyrant and praise him though he
slays them
i in the grove of the temple and in the
shadow of the citadel
i've seen the freest among you wear
their freedom as a yoke and a handcuff
and my heart bled within me for you can
only be free
when even the desire of seeking freedom
becomes a harness to you
and when you cease to speak of freedom
as a goal and a fulfillment
in truth that which you call freedom is
the strongest of these chains
though its links glitter in the sun and
dazzle your eyes
this video was sponsored by blinkist
for many of us the list of books and
authors we would like to explore
and learn from is knowingly too large to
ever complete
at least in the near future and as time
continues on
the list only grows becoming more
daunting and less attainable
the book summary app blinkist helps
solve and prevent this problem
by condensing thousands of complete
non-fiction books into around 15 minute
summaries
blankist allows you to more easily reach
all the books on your list as well as
keep up with new ones
without having to give up any more of
your time available in both audio and
written form
accessible even while offline blinkist
summaries conveniently and efficiently
provide you with the main ideas
and key takeaways of books anywhere
anytime
of course some books you want to read
through and through but many others are
most likely just never going to be
reached on your list
and blinkist helps you sift through and
determine which are which
and leave no book unturned and better
yet for the books and topics you do want
to explore further
blinkist also provides complete audio
books of select titles
as well as podcast summaries from
popular podcasts allowing you to move
both deep and wide across subjects
directly within the app
if you're interested in learning more
about topics related to the self and
consciousness
blinkist has some great titles like
thoughts without a thinker
psychotherapy from a buddhist
perspective which explores the
relationship between psychological
states
and notions of the self with reference
to the buddhist tradition
if you're interested the first 100
people to visit blinkist.com
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description we'll receive one free
week of unlimited access
as well as twenty five percent off a
full membership the free 7-day trial
can be cancelled at any time within the
trial period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
you